so you've played your games boys you've
had your cute little list time to show
you what a real you've talked your talk
let's see real 3x3 looks like let me
show you this let me show you this all
right we got some bangers there we go
that that that's a list what a [__]
list all right all right all right all
wait wait just to confirm tell me your
British without telling me your British
just to confirm uh this is a list of
foods right yeah what is that doing that
beer is a food in [__] Germany Conor
oh beer beer is food not a food it's
food I drink beer as a food substitute
it's it's liquid bread yeah it's it's
it's
food how is it not food sorry I mean
it's like 300 calories carbs a drink
it's it's carbonated it's nice food you
drink it yeah but I yeah but you can
drink some you drink miso is that it
okay hold on that's the least of my
worries there's there's other things to
point out here Dy dirty with this beans
and toast picture you [__] I I didn't
get these pictures that is the worst
picture of beans on toast I gave my list
to the producers and they gave me the
sloppiest saddest looking beans on toast
I've ever seen in my life okay so we got
McCoy's chips listen right uh crisps
actually chips they're [__] chips
what are you [__] talking about
they're
chips I don't believe this crisp look at
your flag and remind remind yourself who
you are all right you belong to us okay
so those are crisps uh these are
specifically toys crisp these are
bangers there's not a single occasion
where if offered to me I will I will say
no to these they're just so godamn they
are the thing about McCoy that other
Chris need to take a lesson from is that
not only is the texture Godlike the
crunch is immaculate I'm just looking at
this and I'm just like this is so
British tell me you're British without
telling me you're British it is
absolutely packed with flavor each bite
of McCoy overl honestly quite frankly
there's so much green and brown in this
I love I love my green I love my brown
um uh and I you know I thought about you
know honestly what's your favorite
McCoy's flavor oh it's so tough but I
think the cheddar and onion is the
[__] gu flame steak is pretty good
too I love I love and also the salt and
vinegar listen cuz sometimes a British
tradition uh cuz you know in America
right you get a bag of Cris crisps right
they're too big they're like they are
they are commitments in the UK we've
kind of we've got we've perfected the
size of the Cris bag cuz you can have
one you can feel like I'm getting but
you can also be like I'm going to have
three bags is it healthy no but I would
regularly just eat all three flavors the
good thing about MC is that I believe
it's all crinkle cut right all crinkle
the superioris superior it is the
superior crisp and it's a bit it's a bit
thicker than like Walkers max if you go
to the UK please try McCoy they are
[__] I was converted I I love McCoy
as well McCoy are great I totally agree
with that I honestly like The McCoys
could be a part of the the meal deal the
bottom cuz it's kind of they kind of
they go hand in hand cuz I I really
wanted to put Indian food on here but I
didn't know which Indian food
specifically I I was debating to put
Indian cures on but but I I don't have a
favorite if you put a gun in my head it'
be mutton Curry but mutton Curry is so
it's it could be whatever spices you put
in it yeah for me it's tie between
mutton and Kemo and I and I and I feel
like I can't just put a cuisine on there
cuz that's not fair you know cuz that's
like saying like you didn't put you
wanted to put barbecue but you pick ribs
right I can't do that with Indian food I
love food so much I couldn't pick one
but McCoy man I mean sometimes you I
we're sleeping on snacks in our 3x3 is
what I'm realizing no none of you guys
put snacks down I actually had a snack
on there and I took it off what did you
have on there you you guys would like
the reason I took it off is because I
don't think anyone would have heard of
it um there's this like Thai fish snack
okay called tle you told me about this
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh it's it's kind of
like it's available in Japan as well uh
she's caught something different but
it's like also like a little bit spicy
as well I I would have put Red Rock Deli
chips uh which I still think are the
best CH potato chips out there only in
Australia though but I put Easter eggs
that's give me them when I'm there now
that's a snack to me Easter eggs Easter
eggs I think it's it's too easy to look
at meals and think main meal of dinner
right you put you put some breakfast
ones and you put some dessert there and
I I wanted to make sure I was getting a
variation of snacks in there too soine
that's why I you went so far that you
put an alcoholic beverage as well beer
is food you can't change my mind uh none
of this you know I think you know would
is it the best alcohol uh yes 100% 100%
100% for me beer is the best alcohol uh
I used to think that but I don't think I
think that anymore I think I think you
know I roll my eyes when I when I go to
places in America and they're like we
have like skull [__] IPA it's is they'll
call it that or they'll call it like bum
scratch IPA you're like what the [__] is
this [__] it's like an 8% outbe you're
like what the [__] is this just give me
a give me something good give me like
a close to being the perfect alcohol if
it didn't have the [__] calorie
content yeah what I you know labels bro
as I mentioned I I I do as I mentioned I
do enjoy alcohol-free beer I this the
one in Japan they do they do no calorie
no carbs alcohol free beer and it tastes
it scratches that it of beer it's
fantastic but it's not of food um normal
beer is food yeah liquid bread I agree
beer is food uh you can't have that as a
meal you you can't have that as a meal
you most certainly can okay gone all
I've had a few nights where I've only
had a beer and I went home full yeah
I've had I've had that was a mistake it
was a mistake but I still went I've had
evenings where I've you know just been
like all right I'm I have the beer and
I'm kind of bloated and I'm like I'm
kind of good yeah I'll just keep
drinking
beer that's like should I no but I do
yeah not often do I do that game's game
uh beer is food you can't change your
mind I was I was about to make an
argument and then I realized it was
going to be a really hot take go on Sir
coward you w okay okay I can't I can't
have just soup as a meal either if you
if you just give me liquid as a meal
it's that's like not a meal to me beer
is better than soup uh I would agree
with you except I could easily just have
miso soup not as a meal no you can't
have miso soup just be like okay alcohol
alcohol alcohol is considered a food
item because it supplies your bodies
with
calories
and a SE crayons uh no cray cray they
don't have that much they don't have
enough to calories no you can you can
you can have like a thousand calories of
beer easily so any drink with calories
is Count counts as food no it's not it's
not so water is not food it's got like
carbs it as well you know don't don't
give me this [__] this is like the same
this is like the same [__] where like
hot doger sandwich well technically it's
like two piece it's like no just don't
drink look the important thing is the
important thing is if I order a [__]
meal and all you give me is [__] beer
I'm going to be like yo where the food
where the food at I get some little
snackies with it but the beer is the
main food yeah usually the McCoy pairs
yeah the McCoy with the be that's they
they go hand in hand often um so yeah
beer I I I recognize as food and I love
love beer a lot um and then in the
middle which is not a great photo I
really uh not the middle sorry the
Middle top middle it's not a great you
even know that shaki it's shaki but it
looks kind of bad in this no I recognize
the
that's like Denise
suu that is not a flattering looking
that is a very midl looking that is what
the average sh look like that is what it
looks like what the tomatoes on the side
you don't normally get tomatoes on the
side so do you do do you want to defend
this because I like it but I like it but
it's not my favorite what I think that
that is what I think of which is like
dude you got have it's okay I think of
like the [__] nak 400 Yen shaki you
know oh there's some places that do it
so [__] good shaki is um just kind of
like ginger pork Ginger pork it's like
Grilled Ginger pork and uh it's just
great if you have like good quality pork
and you you have some really thick sauce
go so well with rice my problem with
suar Yaki is kind of what this picture
is it's like a lot of the times it just
looks depressing I don't I don't want
this green look at that look at that
picture the only thing that out
depresses that picture is the beans on
toast you know one of my favorite sugar
yakis was the one that that uh Mata used
to do before they changed the recipe
[__] uh they made their pork worse
for some reason and uh used to be great
so like the type in like matsa shaki
probably because probably because people
weren't [__] going to matsa to get
Shak were going there to get they were
they were being cucked and they changed
the menu uh it's this amazing like
Comfort traditional Japanese food you've
got to try it it's [__] god tier look
at that pick I mean yeah like for me
that's not that's not sh mat shaki which
one is it probably the left one right um
the very the very right one looks more
similar to it I mean look the left one
yeah shaki for sure is great it's it's
amazing comfort food for God it looks so
bad but it tastes so good it does taste
amazing out of out of the you know
incredibly visually you know appealing
Japanese foods that exist out there this
one is definitely not I wondering how
they [__] up presenting show like
Japanese are like the Masters present
you can't make that look good listen
Jo I love it Ramen I love it but when I
think about like something that makes
you feel good inside shaki just does
something to me close to putting G are
on my
3x3 I had G and I took it off as well um
you know I just think of all the
Japanese foods that really gives me a
sense of comfort and this is one of them
um it's just such a good whole uh eating
experience and if you come to Japan I
really recommend trying it it's not
thought about as one of the great
Japanese Foods um it never gets get love
but it's
fantastic Japanese side dish that I
[__] hate that you can see on that
shogo Yaki dish the Cabbage it's the
[__] really thinly sliced cabbage
it's
like I hate it yeah yeah it is it is
often it kind of makes me feel like a
horse eating hay you know it has it has
negative flavor is it is always the
worst like I'm shooting that
[__] forever every time I see
this on a plate I'm like you had empty
space in the plate and you did not know
how to fill up that unless there is like
a bang of dressing you go to like some
Catu places but I hate it I hate it they
call it salad as well it's this is not a
salad it is not a salad salad requires
multiple elements involved you know what
I mean so like yeah but the only time I
actually like that is when you have cats
on CU you catsu cuz you need you need
something to chill out the [__] oil
and it kind of works but um yeah I mean
it's one one that I would recommend is
it the best food ever uh no but it's
it's definitely a huge compat food yeah
for sure it's up there let's talk about
something that is the best food ever
right now danish hot dogs specifically
hot dogs in general well that's a d
that is a Danish hot dog which is is a
god tier hot dog which is the best the
best hot dog the only hot dogs I love
all dogs all right I love all types of
dogs you know you can get like uh German
style right you can get more British
style hot dogs which are typically just
really thick sausages that are smaller
like in length I don't really count
British like sausages well they're in
like the hot they're they're in a bun
there's a sausage in a bun it has sauce
on it it's a hot dog uh whether you like
it or not that is true um the
traditional hot dog that we all we all
familiar as the American one they are
they have cockroaches in them probably
hairs who knows what else rat feces
probably something else but Mand does it
tastes good I [__] love it even like
going to like a ball game which I don't
do why why' you like it I just [__]
love it you know I'm say it I genuinely
do not like those kinds of hot dogs I
love those [__] dogs I just think hot
dogside from like the danger shot dogs I
just think they're [__] overrated
yeah I okay chili dogs I [__] oh chili
dogs CH dogs are CH dogs are regular hot
dogs are boring chili dogs are great not
because of the hot dogs because of the
chili you no it's it's it's part and
it's part of the texture which one
earlier it's part of the snap I love the
bread and I love this the bread to Sauce
to meat ratio it's perfect I really like
you know saus
on I used to think hot dogs would just
eight cuz in my mind I was only thinking
about the American hot dogs and then we
had the Danish hot dogs on
tour there's different levels of that
you can get but I love all dogs I want
all dogs in my mouth regardless of
quality um you know I just want them
all um I like yeah I I admit the Danish
hot dog probably Superior to most hot
dog do you prefer a hot dog over like
just a traditional sausage in a bun most
of the times yeah I like cuz I like the
bread aspect I like the I like the sauce
aspect um you that from a like a [__]
real sausage I mean don't get me wrong
don't get me wrong sausages would be on
this list too but I can't have two
sausages on the list I me the Australian
didn't me saying the sausage sandwiches
better than I love again sausage
sandwiches British sausage budes no no
you guys [__] it up but the
Australians did it the correct way [__]
you talking about yeah you guys cut that
[__] Ino that from us yeah we made it
better you guys cut that [__] in half
and you put two slices of bread that's
too much bread get one slice of bread
diagonally wrap that [__] around you can
hold in one hand you get full sausage we
do it better no no cuz you're it's just
cuz you can't in Australia you you can't
afford more bread actually we don't want
more bread we want more saage you you
guys your
silad I don't it doesn't matter if you
validate him here if you a British
sausage sandwich is also one of my
favorite comt foods as well just sausage
with bread regardless of which
combination it's being put in is is my
probably my favorite food of all time
it's up there it's my number one thing I
will never ever say no to a hot dog or a
British sausage sandwich or a sausage on
its own I just love sausage I hands out
right I'm I'm a born JoJo fan I want
sausage in every single form but I can
ever like not think that hot dog like
every time I've had a hot dog that's an
American hot dog not Danish hot dogs uh
I just can never I can just never not
think I would just prefer a real sausage
100% yeah but if I'm in the occasion I'm
like I'm down the snap is there that's
all I'm looking for the snap the sauce
the bread the quality it tastes so
[__] processed yeah it is it does it
does and it's it's definitely not as
good but it's like it's like eating
pickles
too it's it's it's like you know having
the choice of like a steak or something
and being like actually I would rather
have spam you know well okay well now if
we're talking like American like street
food stuff like you know like say like
you know if you're in New York or
something right there's tons of like
food stands hot dog included I'd rather
just get a [__] Kebab w w w any day
of the week hot dog Kebab or Euro any
day of the week yeah no it's just better
no it's not I've had the I've had hot
dogs from New York like you know food
stands before and it they're just all
right the [__] kebabs and Yos though
when when I tour America I tried every
style of American hot dog as well and
they were all fantastic all theu dog
Tony dogs uh the Ben chili bow dogs and
DC that was an amazing spot you know
they got the Chicago Dogs no Source I
respect the hustle I prefer and then you
were all trumped by uh Denmark so
Denmark also great every I love every
form of sausage so I think it's fine